frau ferien hat ein problem
seit 20 jahren hat sie zu wenig zeit die
manifesta diktiert ihren lebensrhythmus
das bedeutet ständig neu anzufangen mit
neuen mitarbeitern in einer neuen stadt
immer wieder eine bühne für die
zeitgenössische kunst zu schaffen
sie dirigiert fast 100 angestellte an
drei standorten in zürich wo die nächste
ausgabe entsteht und im hauptquartier in
amsterdam
die kunsthistorikerin verwandelt ein
budget von 75 millionen franken in
kritische gegenwartskunst 26 die erste
manifester findet 1996 in rotterdam
statt
die mauer ist gefallen der eiserne
vorhang geschichte doch ost und west
werden nicht zu einem europa da soll die
kultur helfen findet ferien gründet die
manifesta mit um die junge einheit
sichtbar zu machen
kunstschaffende bekommen ihre chance
zeigen arbeiten die frei und provokativ
sind
die wander biennale wird immer größer
erfolgreicher tour durch ganz europa
dann im jahr 2006 die leerstelle in der
manifesta biografie die sechste ausgabe
auf der geteilten insel zypern
sie muss nach konflikten zwischen
griechenland und der türkei abgesagt
werden
doch die meine fester hört nicht auf
gesellschaftskritische fragen zu stellen
acht jahre später eröffnet sie in sankt
petersburg wieder befindet sich die
kunst auf dem politischen minenfeld
ukraine konflikt homophobie zensur
beherrschen russland was tun in der
ermitage hängen porträts homosexueller
künstler putins konservatismus wird
moderne poesie entgegengesetzt
die resonanz ist riesig ferien gelingt
es die autonomie der kunst zu bewahren
weil sie keine konzession eingeht auf
den dialog gehört in die kraft von der
kunst ich glaube auch und ich sehe das
tagein tagaus dass wenn man leute mit
verschiedenen kulturen nebeneinander
setzt dann gibt es natürlich probleme
es gibt auch eine bestimmte maße von
freude und es ist auch eine begriff
füreinander
2018 geht's nach palermo es soll ihre
letzte manifester sein held wie ferien
sagt sie wolle ihr leben zurück wo sich
die biennale sondern sie selbst die
hauptrolle spiele
verständlich nachdem sie 20 jahre lang
für die kunst in die pedale getreten ist